question is uh i have always wondered
why i ache more during my deload week it
doesn't even need to be after an entire
block of training my back tends to ache
more a few days into the deload than it
ever does during my training weeks i
have more nagging aching and pains as
well so
you know basically why might someone
be experiencing more physical discomfort
during deload weeks than you know when
they're actually like actively training
pretty hard
so the
explanation that i've heard for this so
one thing just to note on the front end
uh i've not seen
like direct human research on this so
we're we're purely in the realm of
anecdote and kind of looking around for
potential explanatory mechanisms so
anyone
who is answering this question with a
super high degree of confidence uh
either they're aware of research that i
wasn't
able to find or they're just kind of
bullshitting so just
be aware of that on the front end uh and
i am going to do my best to not [ __ ]
you with this answer um but yeah so the
the explanation that i've heard from
other sources before
is that when you're training hard you're
putting stressors on your body
and as a result your sympathetic nervous
system output ramps up and along with
that comes increases in catecholamine
levels so epinephrine norepinephrine uh
basically adrenaline
and
those chemicals
can to some degree
uh like numb
pain or discomfort responses like you
know i'm sure you've heard anecdotes
from like athletes who maybe have a
rolled ankle but you know they put on an
ankle brace and get on the court and you
know they they just forget that they've
injured their ankle while they're
actually playing and then they get off
the court and like they're limping all
over the place like the the pain comes
back
and so you know maybe maybe that's just
purely due to adrenaline
and
i don't know
that i fully buy that explanation for a
couple reasons one is that it is true
that when you're putting a lot of
stressors on your body
even when you're not
necessarily
um you know
actively exercising your base like your
your catecholamine levels at rest could
still be elevated to some degree so if
you if you track hrv for example heart
rate variability that's one of those
things that it's roughly trying to
assess if you have
a low heart rate variability
even at rest that means your
sympathetic nervous system even at rest
is ramped up a little bit
so um you know that dynamic is in play
but i i think that the
level of sympathetic nervous system
output and the level of adrenaline you
need to like
pretty significantly numb pain is quite
a bit higher than it would be
at rest even if it is somewhat elevated
from baseline you know so when you're
actually training you might get a pretty
intense analgesic response uh like a
pain reducing response from some of
those chemicals but even if they are
slightly elevated at rest i don't know
that it would be enough to be
physiologically relevant
for like numbing pain and discomfort and
another reason that i'm somewhat
skeptical of that explanation
is there are
other things that you can do that can
ramp up catecholamine output that also
have a tendency to
simultaneously increase pain perception
so for example after just like one or
two like very poor or very short nights
of sleep uh sympathetic nervous system
activity will ramp up while you're awake
basically just to try to keep you awake
and alert uh even though you're you're
poorly rested um an inadequate sleep
also tends to be associated with
increased pain perception so there there
are other things that have a similar
effect on the sympathetic nervous system
as a training block would that would
tend to increase pain perception rather
than decrease it so you know that that
is uh
a set of physiological mechanisms that
may be related to this phenomenon to
some degree but i'm skeptical that it
that it fully explains it
one other possibility is just that you
know maybe you ache more because you're
moving less overall so in in kind of
like
the pain and physical rehab literature
one of the things that you see pretty
consistently is that uh just exercise in
general has a
pretty robust and consistent general
analgesic effect or in other words like
if you move more you tend to hurt less
um
just you know not
not in all conceivable situations and
all conceivable
things that might be causing pain
but in general
if you're if you're very sedentary
or if your activity levels decrease
quite a bit that could make you hurt a
little bit more and if you're a little
bit more active you tend to just be in a
little bit less discomfort um
so you know that could be all that's
going on like it's your d-load week so
you're you're taking it easier in the
gym and maybe as a result like or even
purposefully one of the things people
will often do when they're deloading is
they just try to take it easy in general
like the idea being you know i'm trying
to rest i'm trying to recuperate so i'm
not going to go out of my way to be
active or i might even go out of my way
to be
a bit of a couch potato this week to
really
you know let myself fully recuperate
from this training block i just did so
you know that that could just be the
dynamic at play like your overall
activity levels are lower um you know
and as a result the general levels of
discomfort you feel are a bit higher so
that's another potential explanation
again i don't
i i don't think that would be a complete
explanation of this phenomenon but that
could be another
input in play
and then another
potential explanation
is it could just be a matter of of your
brain basically filtering the inputs
coming to it
and
kind of giving primacy to
whatever the most intense
input is so
that was that was a very bad just
introduction to this explanation but
basically like you're training hard
maybe you're experiencing some pretty
intense or you know at least like
moderate doms delayed onset muscle
soreness so you know it could be that
those
sensations like maybe a little back pain
maybe some joint aches or whatever um
like maybe those things
are there all the time but
there there's kind of a finite amount of
stuff that your brain can make you aware
of like your your conscious mind is is
limited in terms of like how much you
can perceive and process all at once and
so it could just be a matter of like you
know your your brain is trying to send
you what it perceives to be the most
relevant information and so you know it
makes you
aware of pain and discomfort and so it
could just be that you're you're
experiencing enough muscle soreness when
you're training hard that those kind of
like
lower level discomfort signals that are
getting to your brain uh aren't intense
enough to kind of get pushed into your
conscious
perception uh and then once you remove
some of those other uh like
just uncomfortable sensations uh as a
result of training then maybe some more
of that low level stuff uh is now
you know the most intense discomfort
you're feeling and so your brain just
kind of pushes that into your conscious
awareness so that that could be what's
going on as well
all of which is to say i think of those
three things i mentioned all of them
could be contributing none of them could
be contributing it's hard to say we
don't know for sure
so just generally interpret that as food
for thought